an engineer was kidnapped from outside
his home in Riyadh Saudi Arabia he was
beaten thrown into prison and tortured
into confessing to a wave of car bombs
that he didn't commit
confessions of an innocent man is a
story of surviving two years in that
prison next he speaks about it for about
an hour to half good evening everyone
and welcome to a very special event with
an exceptional guest tonight you're
going to hear from a truly remarkable
individual with a shocking story a tale
of a privileged if somewhat bored
Westerner working in a foreign country a
man who probably believed he was living
safely within the begrudging tolerance
of an oppressive regime and then in one
moment his life changed forever
literally snatched off the streets of
Riyadh in Saudi Arabia charged for a
crime that he could not have committed
William Sampson was thrown into a Kafka
s world designed it appears to strip him
first of his sense of security then of
his dignity and ultimately of his
humanity he found himself in a cold
heartless world with no way out no
avenues of Appeal no white knights he
was helpless
there was no right answers no confession
no level of obedience could stop the
torture his book Confessions of an
innocent man takes you through in
gut-wrenching detail his incredible
two-and-a-half year ordeal until his
release in August 2003 is a story that
will make you distressed and angry and
ashamed of some of the people who
represent this country around the world
but there's another dimension to this
story the dimension filled with hope and
inspiration
inspiration because ultimately this man
was able to keep his sense of identity
intact in spite of his captors brutality
they broke his body he nearly died of a
heart attack he suffered permanent
injuries as a result of the torture but
they failed to break his spirit he
emerged emotionally intact if not a
little annoyed as he said to me in our
previous conversation and ready to fight
as one could only imagine
William Sanson 's life has been altered
forever by his ordeal he has dedicated
himself to the pursuit of a compensation
from Saudi Arabia a country which Canada
by the way maintains diplomatic
relations with a country that even today
denies the abuse he and his fellow
prisoners so clearly endured he has also
committed his life to exposing the
chilling duplicity of those spineless
Canadian diplomats you'll read about in
his book and remarkably to studying the
law so that he can fight on behalf of
other victims of torture around the
world mr. Samson will read from his book
shortly and then I hope we can talk
about his work today and as we move into
the future and how we as citizens of a
country that officially does not allow
torture and yet trades with countries
that do how we can get involved will end
the evening by giving you the audience
an opportunity to ask mr. Samson some
questions ladies and gentlemen please
join me in welcoming William Sampson
[Applause]
the section of the book that I'm going
to read you takes place about the fifth
night of my incarceration about two days
prior to that I'd had my house searched
at which I was present and I have was
certain that my house cleaner had also
been arrested entering my property on
that night so two nights later on that
fifth night I was reflecting on this
whilst I was an interrogation session
sitting opposite Khalid or one of my
interrogators on the night my house was
searched I had noted that the bicycle
belonging to Sultan and my house cleaner
was inside the walls of my garden
leading me to believe that he had been
ensnared in this nightmare though I did
not see him then I was correct in
believing that he had been arrested this
glimmer of recognition filled me with
both shame and remorse if I had not been
arrested he would still be free as my
mind churned with the weight of these
emotions there came a scream so loud and
piercing that Khalid halted in
mid-sentence to stare at the door the
sheer power of the agony it contained
made the hair stand up on the back of my
neck
even as accustomed as I had then become
to the horrors of that place how long
that scream lasted I do not know but
probably no more than four or five
seconds it seemed to make time stand
still the silence that followed in its
wake was eerie as Khalid and I stared
toward its location in anticipation our
state of near mesmerized ation was
broken by the third officer bursting
into our room speaking agitatedly in
Arabic carlitz sprang from behind the
desk and scurried out of the room with
the messenger unusually no guard was
ushered in to sit with me so I sat there
alone encumbered by both handcuffs and
shackles but with my hands in front of
me wondering what had gone wrong
eventually I became aware of the fact
that I was alone and I began to examine
the desk looking for anything that
looked like the keys to my restraints
what I would have done had I found the
means to remove them I do not know the
objective of becoming unencumbered was
all that mattered my desperation would
have directed my actions from that point
from beyond the office I could hear the
opening and closing of doors and Terce
shouted words in Arabic whatever was
happening it was
obviously a grave import after a few
minutes a futile perusal I gave up on my
task and stared out of the window into
the night soon when the fury outside
subsided the door opened and Carl had
entered accompanied by another officer
and two uniformed guards they stood me
up
placed a blindfold over my eyes then
guided me back to my cell the blindfold
had been applied in haste providing me
with a limited view of the floor for a
few feet in front of me by inclining my
head just a little I could get a
reasonable view of the people moving in
the hallway I am certain this was
unintentional and to be frank I would
not have minded being spared what I next
saw as we arrived at the stairwell I
noticed the floor and the descending
steps were smeared with a red fluid as I
walked down stairs my feet could not
avoid smearing it further I could feel
the liquid seep through the thin cloth
of my socks leaving a sensation of both
stickiness and slipperiness a somewhat
contradictory impression but that was
the sense of it I knew that it was blood
quite a copious amount of it it dawned
on me that had that it had previously
been an integral part of the poor
bastard who screams I had heard whatever
had been done to him it was severe
enough to cause a major hemorrhage
probably resulting in his death when
finally I was attached to the door of my
cell I went over in my mind the events I
had witnessed moments before I concluded
that the blood that now stained my feet
belonged to Sultan and that he was
probably dead
so it was that I came to believe I had
inadvertently played a part in the
demise of a poor Indian man who's
passing left behind a widow and two
young daughters who had been dependent
on the small remittance remittances he
sent from his various jobs the sense of
guilt that I now felt was overwhelming I
believed myself responsible for what had
just happened that his blood was on my
hands these thoughts did not at that
time help my fragile emotional state
feeling responsible for the death of
another no matter how indirectly is not
an easy burden to bear and certainly not
under the circumstances I then found
myself in in time I would learn to use
this sense of responsibility to motivate
me in my actions but originally all it
did was add to my
sense of futility and hopelessness I
have often wondered whether the events I
witnessed that night had been staged to
frighten me
the whole thing could have been a
performance but I'm sure it was not
particularly with the information
obtained after my release at that time
though primary among my reasons for
believing that it was not staged and
that some ill-fated individual had died
that night was the behavior of my
captors khalid and his squalid quoter ii
were and probably still our unsubtle in
everything they do their acting
abilities were risible and transparent
to me even in the state they had reduced
me to the sense of panic and urgency
that this incident caused was too real
and the expressions on the faces of my
captors unguardedly reflected this more
than two years later some months after
my release I managed to determine better
what happened that night
having been in prison for as long as I
had I'm released as hurriedly as I was I
lost contact with several of my friends
in Saudi Arabia and had not
reestablished these links I reserve as a
result of my writing a series of
newspaper articles some former
colleagues got in touch via the
newspaper one evening in October 2003 I
was able to phone a friend with whom I
had worked as I explained what I thought
had happened to Sultan my friend
interrupted me informing me that I was
mistaken
he explained that Sultan whose usual job
was as a tea boy at the fund had been
arrested but was released within two
days and had not been tortured he also
told me that upon his release Sultan
informed some of my colleagues about my
fate Sultan was at least partly of what
aware of what had happened to me four on
the night that my house was searched he
had been arrested entering the property
thus while I was shepherded around the
house by my captors so too is he in
order that neither he nor I would catch
sight of each other although I did not
see him he had managed to catch a
glimpse of me and comprehended the
difficulties that I would probably face
Sultan informed my colleagues and they
in turn informed both the British and
Canadian embassies of my arrest who
would thus have known of my
disappearance within five days of my
arrest as this information was related
to me I felt the burden lift
my shoulders sultan had been spared and
had not been caught up in my nightmare
the sense of relief of joy and of
elation that this brought stayed with me
for only a brief time whose blood was
that that I walked through that night in
the interrogation centre in the joy of
discovering that Sultan was alive I had
forgotten that someone else must have
died instead who were they did anyone
know that any government care till the
last question I that I know the answer
to be no as for my own feelings I
instinctively believe that having gained
my own freedom I now had a duty to speak
out not just about the treatment that I
received but also about the treatment
that even then was being meted out to
those whom I must have left behind as I
watched now the unfolding of current
events I feel this Duty more acutely as
hundreds if not thousands are still
subject to the inhumane brutality of
corrupt dictatorship and ofttimes our
own governments collude or assist in
this barbarity on that night in late
December 2000 I had been spared
prolonged interrogation through the
death of another and I had my own misery
to wallow in and wallow I did as I stood
rapt in my blanket
soon the morning meal arrived and I went
through the motions of eating giving
myself as much time as possible to sit
on the mattress and stretch out my legs
I attended to my rice diary for what it
was worth and then called for the guard
once in the toilet I stripped off and
washed as best I could
I took my socks and began to scrub them
under the tap watching streaks of
rose-tinted water drain away I replaced
my clothes slipping the wet socks on to
my feet their coolness gave me some
little momentary relief from the burning
pain in the company of a guard I
returned to my cell - sleepless
anticipation and whatever new
depredations lay before me
please have a seat over here one of the
things I remember thinking when I first
read your book was the incredible detail
that you were able to recall painful
detail really to read how were you able
to do that well two things really from
the moment I was arrest that I knew I
had to try and remember as much as I
could just in case I ever got out of
there I did eventually come to the
conclusion that I wasn't getting out of
there but I still kept up that activity
of trying to make sure I remembered
everything just in case I did you know
win the lottery and get the hell out of
the place but I did recommence of
surviving that place we're about the
same as winning the lottery I'm possibly
even less and I then tried to construct
means of finding of reminding me of what
happened so I as I said I constructed
the rice diary in the first instance
when I eventually was allowed a book
what I would do is I would fold down
pages to mark the passage of time I
would put tears in specific places along
the pages to show when I'd been
interrogated when I'd been tortured when
I'd had in an interview from the embassy
when I'd been in hospital and although
that didn't give me an accurate record
it gave me a sort of an incident report
is the best way of describing it and
while the rest of the time I spent in my
prison cell I would be quite frankly
didn't have exactly much the do solitary
confinement is you know you've hardly
got a busy social calendar I would spend
my time walking around the cell and
during those excess periods of exercise
I'd make use of the time by going over
and recounting to myself every detail
that I had I'd had that of everything
that had happened to me so that I didn't
forget a single thing and then I would
confirm that by going through the book
diary as I called it to ensure that I
knew the timing of the events when I was
released from prison about two or so
weeks afterwards I sat down with my book
Diaries and then wrote out about 90
she's a bit of notes all in sort of
shorthand of each and every event an
incident that I could remember because
now with two years in the writing of the
book things are fading and becoming
jumbled and I'm glad I actually did that
exercise what was it like to write the
book was it a deeply emotional
experience to have to relive and that
sort of detail some of the things that
you went through no it was a pain in the
neck I'm being perfectly frank and
honest there I mean I didn't I've never
had a great deal of difficulty
remembering the brutality that I was
subjected to if I'm likely to get
emotional about something or find a
memory difficult is when I recall
brutality that I might have witnessed to
others or I thought was happening to
others as in the passage that I just
read but as for myself I tend to be
somewhat dispassionate about the things
that happened I mean I can review them
quite almost coldly so it wasn't that
there was a problem for me when I was
writing the book it was trying to find
I'm not a writer by trade and it was
trying to find the words to convey
accurately what the hell happened to me
in there both physically and emotionally
without it turning into a dis formal
legal deposition or a police report
because those things miss the emotional
intensity of what happens you know
whether or not I've been successful in
that I'll leave my critics to say but
that's was what I wanted to try and do
and that's therefore where I had my
biggest difficulty when writing the book
as far as good some people have asked me
about catharsis and in reality there
wasn't anything cathartic about writing
the book when I did write something that
was cathartic is when I worked with
Francine Dube of the National Post and
produced those articles and that was an
incredibly stressful seven days but a
very necessary seven days harder on her
perhaps than on you I think yes because
at the end of it I was relieved at the I
was relieved at the end of it for her
she was shell-shocked I mean she's a
fairly tough and resilient individual
and has reported on quite a wide ranging
series of things but she'd never had to
sit down with a tortured survivor and go
through seven days of unremitting
memories and I didn't spare her any
blush
she heard everything all of the details
that you see in that book including the
rape that happened she knew about at the
time but we decided not to put it in the
stories for various personal reasons at
that moment and she had to go through
watching me breaking down all the time
for over the 7 days while I was
recounting every every minor detail of
it so that we can in sort through all of
those to produce the newspaper articles
and so it cannot have been very easy I
know I know it wasn't very easy on her
tell me what you hope the book will
achieve what is it that you hope can be
done through this book
well there's in reality two things two
primary things one it is my record of
events there's been a lot of political
spin going on out there about what is
and what has and has not happened in
Saudi Arabia and this has presented me
with my first opportunity to sit down
and say this is the reality of what I
faced this is this is what is indelibly
etched in my memories my memory this is
what happened to me
secondly I also wanted to hopefully
achieve providing by providing a record
of what torture really is it's not some
little arcane concept that happens in a
faraway place and we don't have to think
about it this is the reality of torture
this is the reality of the barbarity
that governments like Saudi Arabia
subject their own citizens to and
foreign citizens resident in that
country and these are the people who are
in theory our allies and particularly
now that we have a lot of the
anti-terrorism debate going on and you
have people trying to justify various
forms of brutality and coercive
interrogation as legitimate means for
interrogating terrorism suspects and
claiming that they are doing it to
protect the wider population
I want the wider population to know do
you want this done in your name do you
think this level of barbarity actually
makes you safer I personally think the
answer to those two questions should be
no and I hope that it adds something to
that debate how do you explain the
behavior of the muppet and other
Canadian
diplomats in the first instance I can
compete quite honest with you in the
first instance I think it was stupidity
on his part I mean no when I first met
the chap where it was at I've been
arrested before I was arrested for this
I'm explaining this in the book but
before I was arrested for the long haul
I was briefly arrested in October of
2000 I was driving over to a friend's
house and the Matawa had raided the
villa next door to them didn't find the
owner of the villa who has had a huge
still in the place so they raided my
friend's house and they were brewing
wine and they got arrested and I drove
right into the middle of the raid and
got picked up I spent the weekend in
prison I then went into the embassy
afterwards and reported what had
happened and that's when I met them up
it for the first time and he sat there
and gave me this you know wonderful sort
of glowing resume of his incredible
actions in Rwanda which I was wondering
who he was advertising it to because I
certainly wasn't hiring and then
proceeded to tell me that Saudi Arabia
was just like Africa and I thought oh
good that's a bit like saying Canada's
like Mexico this is what this is the
calibre of first consuls we've got in
this country so I left the embassy
annunzio defied by my experience of
meeting this chap and then all of a
sudden the discover I had to deal with
him in prison
so my first impressions of him were not
particularly well informed and not
particularly bright and then I began to
realise that he may well be mendacious
as well throughout my incarceration
which was again hardly thumps a
realization you wanted to have when this
person is your only link with the
outside world this is the only link you
have to your family who are probably
going through hell wondering what is
happening to their child what is
happening to their cousin and yet you
chose not to name him can you explain
why there are legal reasons for that and
also fairness to be quite honest with
you in my case it is it is fairness a
lot of the things I say about him or my
word against his and in reality if I was
to
publish them I could I could quite
frankly find myself in a liable Court
and I'm because it's my word against his
I would the burden of proof would fall
on my shoulders and I might probably
lose that but that isn't to be quite
honest with you or worry because I've
said some fairly rough things about
various politicians I have not been to a
fright frightened of libel in this
particular case though if I had the
means of proving my allegations
I would certainly name him but as I do
not it would be unfair of me to make
allegations which are my word against
his and name the child and possibly ruin
his career and ruin his life he's not
someone who's in the who's not someone
who is in the public eye as a politician
is and therefore should not have to face
such allegations the type of allegations
that I faced in the first place in some
respects your entire book is your word
against someone else at Saudi Arabia has
never acknowledged what you report in
there how does that make you feel
knowing that you have to deal with that
level of denial that frustration and
what are your prospects if you are able
to move ahead with your lawsuit well
I've always known that the Saudi
Arabians are a culture of denial and
I've always been quite cynical about our
own political establishment anyway
so I've not been surprised nor oh I've
been particularly frustrated by the
behavior of the politicians both in
Canada in Britain and in Saudi Arabia
they behave pretty much as I've expected
them to disappointing though that is at
least they're they're behaving true to
form and they're predictable so I don't
find that that frustrating they have
their denials and they can continue to
make their denials on what I have are a
series of friends who spent their time
in prison with me who bear the same
scars that I do scars that we have
proven exist by going to the Parker
Institute in Denmark and so while I may
not be able to prove every single
allegation absolutely what I have is
substantial corroborating evidence in
the form of a report from the Parker
Institute that states categorically that
I was tortured in the manner pretty much
in the manner that I had stated that I
reported in the book which in turn acts
to sort of support if not absolutely
corroborate everything that I've said
and so for me I don't really worry about
it I haven't I can prove that I've been
tortured I leave them to continue with
their denials as for the court case I
suspect in a court room as our lawyers
are fairly confident if we ever get into
a high court to actually sue those that
abused us and those that gave the orders
for the abuse we will win we will be
able to substantiate our claims
sufficiently in a civil action the
burden of proof in a civil action versus
a criminal action is slightly lower it
has to be beyond it is what is within
within the bounds of probability in a
civil action versus beyond reasonable
doubt in a criminal action and so
technically it's easier to win in a
civil action when you're making a claim
against someone than it is in a criminal
so we are likely to win in a civil
action because we can corroborate most
of what we say to within the reasonable
grounds reasonable probability however a
compensation that's unlikely to happen
what I will have established is a series
of precedents which will allow others
who've been abused such as myself to go
straight into the courtroom at the first
opportunity to begin the process of
seeking compensation and in some of
those cases they will get compensation
but there is one commonality to all
torture survivors such as myself that I
have found and that is a desire to be
able to speak and to be able to
demonstrate in a courtroom or a public
forum that they were abused and to hold
their abusers up for ridicule and shame
and that is what I'm doing in the
courtroom and that is what I hope to
achieve for myself but also make it
easier for others who follow on after me
and there will be others thousands of
others this would bring to end a certain
degree of hypocrisy within our
government and other governments why
does that exist and what is the endgame
under the current circumstances I never
quite understood what the endgame is
other than somewhat Marxist style
analogy or analysis which probably
doesn't play too well in Alberta but
anyway
I sometimes wonder whether or not those
who governess end up with more in common
with those who govern people in other
countries than they have then they more
in common with the governing class in
another country than they do with the
citizens whom they govern and as a
result of that they're actually more
comfortable dealing with Saudi Arabian
government officials than they are
dealing with their own citizenry and
therefore in such a situation you have a
social dynamic developing where they
tend to be more supportive of their own
governing class than they do of the
people who they technically represent
and work for now as I said that is a
somewhat Marxist point of view but I do
believe it has some value in this
situation secondly the government and
the government officials wrap themselves
up in a series of concepts that
everything can done can be done silently
and behind closed doors that one doesn't
want to make waves or rock the boat
because it will affect trade in exchange
that's going on between nations and
those things ultimately are more
important because they will they will
ultimately resolve all the problems and
this is almost a mantra within the
Foreign and Commonwealth Office within
the Department of Foreign Affairs and
Belgium within the Department of Foreign
Affairs and international trade here in
Canada within the State Department in
the United States and it's quite frankly
wrong trade and exchange trade in
exchange does not necessarily stop abuse
it does not necessarily lead to reform
in these countries that's the first
point and secondly when you advertise
the fact that you're more concerned
about your balance of payments with the
country than you are about your own
citizenry what you're doing what you're
saying to that country is go ahead and
kick the crap out of our people because
we don't care yes and your circumstance
I remember you saying when we spoke
before that for perhaps a dozen days
quiet diplomacy might have had some
value the first week or two and beyond
that it had no value that you in your
view yes and in my view I actually have
experience of that a process in reality
what happened was when as I said when I
got arrested in October 2000 my friend
Peter Goldsmith and his wife Annie was
slammed in prison now their employers
Saudi Arabian government employers
didn't come to the
assistance because a copious amount of
alcohol about 500 to 600 liters of home
brewed wine was found on their property
it was Christmas time a mitigating
measurement but I think as Peter should
have said it wasn't mitigating
mitigation of this it was Christmas time
and they were planning on holding a
series of parties there and trust me
when you've got a thirsty group of
expatriates in Saudi Arabia farmers
leaders of wine disappears very very
rapidly but the thing was is that when
first they were arrested we were not
that far away from Ramadan and the
tactic I came up with in the back of my
mind with amongst with Pete Peters
friends was it's an alcohol charge
against a westerner the Saudi Arabians
tend to let those float which they
usually do Ramadan is close if we keep
it quiet keep it out of the media in the
UK and try and orchestrate the families
to send him pleas to the Ministry of
Interior who might be able to smooth
this over so I dictated the tone of a
letter to Peter and his daughter in
London on the phone and had they had it
translated into Arabic and it was
delivered to the Embassy in London a
Saudi Arabian embassy in London a plea
for clemency they were all people they
knew they were all people who weren't
very well which is true Peter was a
diabetic and his wife so was his wife
who also had spinal problems and
osteoporosis and what we did in URI add
was that we also translated the letter
into Arabic and we got it delivered into
the Ministry of Interior to somebody
senior inside the Ministry of Interior
because we had connections that could do
that for us the result was they were
booted out within about the in the
second week of Ramadan bang that was
quite diplomacy at work quiet diplomacy
affected by the the Friends of the
people because one of the things that
happened was reporters were hounding the
family and I managed to get to the
family before the reporters get to them
keep it out of the press if it had
gotten into the British press and Peter
and Andy might have found themselves
spending a year or so in prison so in
that first few weeks a solution was
reached but the plan had been if they
aren't out by Christmas we go big and we
go in the press we get amnesty we get
Human Rights Watch
because the only way the mountain in any
short space of time once the sort of
grace period is over is by bringing
pressure to bear do most expats have a
clear understanding of how far they can
push the envelope where they are safe
and where they are trading going over
the line the answer to that is I don't
think we did I mean I had a fraid I I
had a fairly strong sense of the fact
that things were tightening up in Saudi
Arabia I mean after the first Gulf War
the place kind of went became the Wild
West for a while and there was the tarts
and vicars party that sort of exploded
over half of Riyadh I mean people would
be it was a fancy dress party where you
went as a Tartar as a vicar alright and
you had people cross-dressing and
driving around Riyadh in suspenders and
stockings males right and in a buyers in
the black cloaks and there are people a
photo people had photographs of
themselves taken in shopping centers in
Riyadh that was how you know when you
think of how close the societies and how
strict the enforcement is this tarts
envious big tarts and vicars party that
happened about a couple of years before
I arrived on Saudi Arabia which was the
talk of everybody out there as to how
lakhs things had got that was changing
it had sort of reached that sort of
stage and there with the government was
wheeling that were sort of winding that
back in and I arrived out there and
things were tightening up and I could
feel that and so to my mind the more
discreet you were with your alcohol
consumption and your parties the more
you kept it behind the compound walls
you made sure that people who got drunk
and couldn't drive didn't drive you put
them discreetly in taxis and got them
home without the local Matar getting to
know about these things was sensible a
lot of the expats still felt however
didn't pick up on that and felt
completely Natale fireproof because they
kept referring back to 1995 and 1996
when anything seemed to go in the
expatriate community and you got away
with it and they weren't aware of that
and they also and this was one area
which I operated under the same
misapprehension as the rest of the
expatriates and that is that whilst the
Saudi Arabians would arrest us they'd
throw us in jail and we could get stuck
in the prison for up to a year for
alcohol offenses or certain other types
of social crimes
we were unlikely to be tortured or
severely brutalized if you got arrested
by them at our yes you would get a
beautiful probably get punched in the
rest of it on the night that you were
arrested but once you're in the hands of
the the formal police things would go
much smoother and we all operate under
the misapprehension that we wouldn't be
tortured that UNMISS APRI henchman was
unfortunately very rapidly corrected on
my part and on the part of my friends
and I think throughout the Western
expatriate community very very rapidly
you said you don't believe for a moment
that Khalid and the other two torturers
believed that you were guilty of
anything that you were accused of so
they were literally beating you into
confessing to something that they knew
wasn't true that's great yeah
how bizarre was that it was very very
bizarre to experience it but to be
honest with you there's been a long
history of that not just in Saudi Arabia
and not just in Saudi Arabia I mean go
back as far as the Salem witch trials
yeah these this sort of thing in when
interrogators police officers have
absolute power and are answerable to no
one this happens and unless you have a
system which constantly reviews that and
in which punishment is meted out to
those that abuse their authority and is
properly meted out to to those who
abused their authority it's going to
happen doesn't matter whether it's Saudi
Arabia or Canada or Britain we
fortunately now have reasonably powerful
judiciary's who can oversee those abuses
and we have a system of governments
where our civil liberties are reasonably
respond human rights are reasonably
respected so we're not likely to see
that type of abuse as a form of state
policy but in countries that are
dictatorships like Saudi Arabia like
Uzbekistan like China those abuses are
the norm they're not something that
happens once in a while they're not a
rogue cop going off and trying to get
himself a quick promotion or a quick
result they are the state and so when
you get yourself into that sort of a
circumstance and they start to abuse you
you know that they're setting you up
from the very very first instance and
rarely in those type of places are
they really interested in catching the
criminal particularly in something which
is going to be used as a show trial you
know they may be interested in catching
somebody who may be a car thief or
whatever and getting the right person
they may have some interest in that but
this was a political case it had a
political dimension to it because it was
terrorism
there was a result of that the truth was
of no interest to them for public
consumption what they needed war
scapegoats there were so many dark
moments during your ordeal but maybe
this is a difficult difficult question
to answer but what was what was the
darkest what was the worst what was the
one where you said I'd rather be dead
there were a couple of those but that's
also the point where I began to lose my
fear of death I'd never had a great
degree of fear of death but I began to
welcome be more welcoming of the concept
shuffling off my mortal coil probably
around about day six and a half when I
first confessed when I couldn't take
anymore and I implicated myself
fortunate in that first confession I
didn't implicate anyone else but I also
knew that I would pretty much one part
of me was hoping that that was the end
of the torture the other part of me
hoped that it would be that or not hoped
but realized that the chances are I'd
now be forced to implicate others at
some point and I didn't know how that
was going to go and I did feel pretty I
thought that was the blackest moment
until day 9 when I was raped and that's
when literally I came as close to
permanent emotional destruction as like
as I ever wish to have experienced in my
life we're going to give you and the
audience an opportunity to ask questions
so if he would like to please come
forward and stand in front of the
microphone oh I spilled a couple more
questions while you have an opportunity
to do that but please come forward now
bill one more question before we turn it
over to the audience and that is there
are a lot of people who when they saw
you released and you had the long hair
and you look like quite a mess
they still Madison
said he's gone insane but you say there
was never a moment where you had really
lost your sanity
I came close to losing my sanity in the
day that I was raped the first day that
I was raped very very close but once I
sort of hid that sort of the only way I
can describe it as a personal epiphany
just a piece of poetry to have that rip
that came back to me was stunning
clarity I probably hadn't thought about
that piece of poetry in 20 plus years
just came back to me in a flash and just
somebody told me that I was not going to
break down completely that there was one
small part of me that they would never
get to that would never be destroyed and
from that moment onwards I knew I wasn't
gonna lose my sanity I knew I might lose
my life but that was fine by me
I did however get bloody pissed off of
frequent occasions while I was in prison
and I did behave like a screaming bloody
lunatic which was designed in most part
it was thought out and planned and I'm
quite and I can quite understand why
people who on the outside of it they
hear about a guy I mean you think about
this they hear about a guy who's
wandering around his cell bare naked and
trust me that is not an edifying sight
and bare naked hairy covered in his own
faeces spitting cursing and trying to
bite his guards I don't blame anyone for
thinking I'd flipped I really don't
because if I heard that as an outsider I
would think the person had lost it and
however in my case it was done to
provoke a reaction out of my guards and
it was very very successful over to our
first questioner I've been really
wanting to ask you if if your experience
has made you more fearful or less
fearful over the world around you and
how that changed your personality before
and relative to how you are as a person
now the answer to that is I was never
particularly fearful of anything well
except for spiders and I still am
unfortunately
played a big part in my interrogation
because I had to lose nations about the
damn things but and I'm even less so now
I mean I spent I spent a long time on my
youth doing a lot of climbing and I lost
I knew people who didn't come back from
climbing climbing trips and climbing
expeditions and had always had a sense
of my own mortality
I knew basically I wasn't getting out of
life alive as none of us are so death
was never a great fear to me in that
respect but it wasn't something I
welcomed what I came to in prison
through the brutality was I came to
learn that death was in itself a form of
freedom which is something I never to me
which was not something I would have
thought of before and in terms of
therefore having anything to fear since
I've come out as I said I still have my
minor discomfort when I'm around spiders
but in terms of fear for my own safety
or anything else like that fear that if
anything can happen to me I know I can
survive I don't worry about it I mean if
I if I'd never been able to write this
book and I'd end up panhandling on the
street bugger it I can survive you know
that's what I learned in there it
doesn't matter what happens to me it
doesn't matter whether I'm rich or poor
I can survive and I can remain intact
one way or another and that was a
valuable to me a very very valuable
learning experience in a very very
valuable lesson next question mr.
Sampson bearing in mind what happened to
you how would you recommend that we in
the West treat these oppressive regimes
on a go-forward basis well we don't
fortunately unfortunately have the
resources to nor do we really have the
moral authority to try overthrowing any
of those regimes such as the Mugabe
regime in Zimbabwe or the military junta
in Burma but the simple fact is is that
where there are cases of abuse committed
by those regimes against our own
citizens such as against Zahra Kazemi in
Iran we should be taking these things to
whatever international mechanism exists
treaty organization that exists or
criminal court that exists immediately
not waiting we should be holding up
these regimes to the spotlight of
international law and that's what our
government should be doing for us
for instance Stephane Hashmi Zara's son
has been fighting for justice for his
mother now since her death he's
beginning nowhere with the Canadian
government they've had a couple of dog
and pony shows called trials in Iran and
nothing more than that and the Canadian
government should have long ago applied
to the International Criminal Court in
this matter but will never do so because
it's more worried about trade and
exchange relations with Iran than doing
the right thing what we in the West need
to be doing is actually as government as
far as our governments are concerned
they should be taking these issues more
seriously and applying to the
international institutions like the ICC
in cases like these unfortunately they
don't they should also be repealing
their state immunity acts so that
individuals such as myself who've been
brutalized can actually begin the
process of gaining redress on their own
behalf when they get into a system where
there is a fair and open judiciary but
again it's something they don't want to
do for whatever reason in many respects
some of the diplomats and government
officials may be frightened of
countersuits in other countries against
them because of their own misadventures
in my case what I'm doing is that I am
actually fighting the state immunity act
in the courtroom in the United Kingdom
in the hope of pushing back its
boundaries that I will be able to sue
the individuals and that others like me
will then be able to come out and do the
same thing when we managed if and when
we managed to flood and I do believe
when we manage to flood the courtroom
with our cases we will force the
government to realign its foreign policy
because it'd be too damned embarrassed
with all that hold the government
officials from foreign countries that it
has cozy relationships are now being
dragged into its courtrooms as
individuals here in Canada one thing you
can do is you can support an MP called
Francine the lawn of the bloc québécois
and that might be a strange concept for
you out here in Alberta too to be having
somebody asking you to support a bloc
esteverena separatists well won't you
yeah but Francine alone is trying to
sponsor a private member's bill to
reform the state immunity Act to give
people like myself the right
to pursue justice for ourselves without
having to refer to the state now it's
going to be a private member's bill
which means they're technically won't be
any party whips involved in it but you
could be damn sure the government of the
day is going to throw a three-line whip
down and it spot on it's party members
to try and stop it the block will block
MPs have been given a free ride to to
back the back her private member's bill
when it comes out and they probably will
so we've got we need what is it 162 yes
we need 162 votes to get when this comes
up as a private member's bill we need
162 votes for that to succeed probably
when the next election comes through in
a few next few weeks we'll have the
block we'll be voting for it on mass
that means we've got 50 to get this
through and it's kind of ridiculous that
I can count on separatists to push
through a bill that will protect the
human rights of all Canadians well we've
got to find another hundred and ten
hundred and twenty MPs and other parties
to ensure its success then we've got to
fight the Senate but what you can do is
Lobby your MP to support francine
Lalande on this matter because it is for
me personally it is an important issue
because once individuals like myself can
get into the courtroom force our abusers
to stand before us and be accused and
suffer the ignominy of public exposure
governments will then be forced to take
notice of this and therefore they may
start to reform how they deal with those
countries that torture and may start to
take the International mechanisms and
treaties that they have set up seriously
and apply them properly well as of
Monday you may have better chance of
reaching your MPs as we head into
another election so that could be an
issue the next question - please mr.
Sampson are you a Canadian citizen yes
and I ask that question for two reasons
one when you appeal to the will you call
mr. muppet as you're representing
representative in
in sanity and he did nothing is that
because he didn't like you or do you
find that the general tenor of the of
the diplomatic corps I think no more
concerned with a golf game with their
local counterparts to inquire on this
video I don't think the man hadn't
needed like or dislike me I was a damned
inconvenience I held bells when I was
having my heart attack he was out having
a desert picnic and he was reluctant to
well elect him to terminate that heaven
red having red shake hands at the devil
I find that to be fairly commonplace and
in the United Nations regime the second
question was this morning I heard did an
interview with you on CBC and you the
conversation came up about permission to
sue but that my understanding was that
was in the British Court that's correct
so can you extend or go across the ocean
to to apply or seek leave for a lawsuit
against sorry as a Canadian citizen well
there's a number of things is that
there's a we have a number of hurdles it
does get a bit complicated but what
we're applying for is there is the right
to be able to sue the individuals that
tortures us and those who gave the
orders now once we've succeeded in that
we then have to establish jurisdiction
whether or not we can do that in the
jurisdiction of the ninety Kingdom
considering it as Saudi Arabian
officials that we are suing and what we
have to show there is that we would have
no means of a fair trial by British
standards by the standards of the
British judiciary in Saudi Arabia that's
going to be easy that oddly enough is
going to be easy to establish after
we've established the jurisdiction
question we then have to establish
whether or not the people who we've
named that we want to sue are the right
people now the two people who tortured
us that's a given it begets a bit more
problematic when you come to the
governor of the prison but not that much
so because he would have had to have had
oversight over what was happening to his
prisoners in his prison and he cannot
deny some responsibility for it so we
can nail him it's nailing Prince naive
which is probably problematic and he for
me is the important one the good thing
in this case and it's unfortunately a
bad thing as well is
Saudi Arabia has such a long track
record of human rights abuses that it is
easy enough to prove that as a matter of
state policy and that prints knife has
been running this as a matter of state
policy for the last god knows how many
years he's been Ministry of Interior so
once we have established all of those
things and we have the right and we've
already we've established the right to
sue then established jurisdiction and
the Koran to correct and that we've got
the correct people then the case proper
starts but we should be able to once
we've got that right to sue the
jurisdictional question and whether or
not was doing the right people should be
reasonably easy to establish long-winded
but reasonably easy as for the
applicability of that in Canada there's
a number of good things about that about
what I'm doing in the UK and that is the
basis of Canadian law is the same as
that in the United Kingdom and the
result of that is is that precedent set
in British courtrooms
are quoted here and precedent set in
Canadian courtrooms are quoted there
they're also quoted in other legal
jurisdictions outside of this sort of
former Commonwealth countries which are
or formal British colonial countries
which have a common legal system but
they're not given the same weight and
the interesting thing for me is that in
my appearing at the court of appeal last
October the case of who Shaun moosari
versus the state of Iran which is being
heard here in Canada was one of the
precedents that was being used to try
and deny me the right to justice all
right
the beauty of it is now that if we get
our proof we set our precedent at the
Law Lords and get that set in stone in
British law whose Sangu sorry here in
Canada will then use that prints
identity was denied in the first
instance here in Canada and we're
effectively playing it we're almost
playing a game of legal ping-pong in
some respects the question about your
citizenship is interesting because in in
a moment of anger more than one you
renounced your Canadian citizenship yeah
and and that was when you believe that
the Canadians were less effective than
the British would have been uh well it
wasn't actually then that I first
renounce my Canadian citizenship I had
very very few means of indicating to
people how exactly annoyed I was with
them all right
particularly with the diplomats during
the Interior in the interview sessions
and at which at each one of my
interviews that I had with the embassy
the guys who tortured me were present
and I had very very effective area the
only two things I had that could shock
them in any way or indicate that I was
not happy with them to make them take me
seriously was to refuse to accept the
visit to stay in my prison so which
eventually I did on a permanent basis or
and to renounce my Canadian citizenship
now the first instance instances of my
refusing to accept the visit and
renouncing my Canadian citizenship came
over the fact that they were continuing
to insist that my father be allowed to
visit Saudi Arabia and I did not want
him there and I kept pointing out him I
don't want him here look don't ask me
again
they just didn't take me seriously so I
refused to visit and renounce my
Canadian citizenship and it kind of
shocked them all right which meant they
didn't ask me the question of my father
coming to Saudi Arabia for a good couple
of months after that and I did the same
thing again when they did it the next
time I refused to visit sort of thing
because I I was not did not want my
father being used in some sort of
dog-and-pony propaganda show that there
that the Saudis and the Canadian
government might have been concocting
which is what I thought was happening
aside every been certainly the Saudi
Arabians have used my father's visits as
part of their propaganda campaign to say
the torture couldn't have happened and
the Canadian government is using my
father's visits as a means of saying
that how well they treated me because
they made sure that my father they
brought my father of to see me except
the fact that they didn't bring him my
father paid his on tickets and when he
needed accommodation in Saudi Arabia the
British government gave it to him in the
embassy to protect him however by the
time I came round to towards November of
2001 one I was so fed up with the
embassy officials and their stupidity
and I've now been by that stage
confronted three times by them saying
that I was guilty that was it
I'd had enough renounce my citizenship
refused offer the visits now they never
accepted the renunciations and this is a
curious
point they never accepted my renouncing
my citizenship because they said under
the circumstances it wouldn't be legal
yet they accepted a part they accepted
that the power of attorney I gave my
father given under exactly the same
circumstances was it was legal and they
also accepted that my confessions were
technically legal given under the same
circumstances so it seemed that they
were willing to make their decisions on
an ad-hoc basis not based on anything
other than their own convenience in this
matter
now I haven't renounced my Canadian
citizenship since I came out because
it's my birthright I did it in prison
basically to annoy the hell out of some
people but I am British by birth and I
am Canadian by birth and I'm bammel not
resigning either one of them regardless
what anyone says although if either
country Britain or seto or Canada makes
it illegal for me to be a dual national
I'll just become Irish because I've got
an Irish grandmother and I can probably
get a passport there I'm not going to
have my dick birthright dictated to me
by by government bureaucrats sorry if
that sounds a little bit ridiculous next
question
certainly I empathize with you on the
question of the foreign diplomats and
that I worked for the Canadian Embassy
in Madrid at one point and I just was
there now actually like our new
ambassador not all of them are bad and
fortunately there's just there is a yeah
on the whole that was pretty scary we
spent most of the time eating smoked
salmon and having parties and we didn't
do any really we had no nothing going
with Spain at all and I could see
through your text or to interrupt you
these are your tax dollars at work folks
to ask you as a longtime member of
Amnesty International I might have
missed that because with a little warm
in here at one point but was Amnesty
International of any use to you what did
you make any were you just unable to get
through to them or what was the what's
your feeling about Amnesty International
in this in this affair where I think
they somebody somewhere they couldn't be
Britain they couldn't be Canada because
you're a citizen in both places maybe
but somebody should have been doing
something there it's totally a case for
amnesty I would have thought well the
answer is that Amnesty International did
raise the awareness in this case as did
Human Rights Watch as did redress which
is london-based charity for redress for
victims of torture as did the
Association and defense of the wrongly
convicted in in Toronto
all of which we're told that they
shouldn't all of all these organizations
were told to tone down their activities
by the various governments of British
the Belgians the Canadians and quite
thankfully they didn't because the only
way of protecting somebody who is in
prison is being abused is keeping their
name in the public eye for until the day
that they are released in their free the
governments will tell you that you put
the person at risk of death or execution
if you annoy the government's concerned
well from the place that I was in
as I said death was its own freedom
death was its own release and if by
speaking out a risk is taken that you
might not make it out of prison it's a
risk you as the victim are willing to
have someone take on your behalf and in
reality by speaking out on these cases
you rarely do put someone at an
increased risk you actually protect them
but the government's refuse to admit to
that fortunately these are organizations
like Amnesty International and Human
Rights Watch that don't listen to them
to the central governments and do keep
people's names out there in public while
they're in prison unfortunately some of
those names still get lost because there
are thousands of us who have been in
those situations and thousands who are
still in there at the moment next
question you said something about an
institution and Denver Institute in
Denmark that was proving that you were
tortured um how do they prove that and
as their findings taken seriously the
answer to that is is that the findings
the methods that they use have been
peer-reviewed in the medical literature
so they're admissible in court and have
been used in court cases already to
establish torture that's the first thing
the second thing is it's a place called
the parkour Institute which is a
charitable institution run primarily
with monies donated from a rather
liberal American philanthropist not all
Americans are bad as the brand Anna just
George Bush
Dick Cheney and Donald Rumsfeld sorry
and that bloody Attorney General of
theirs Gonzales personally I know of a
nice prison cell I'd like to put the lot
of them in all right anyway I'm sorry -
sorry - get away from your point there
I'm very bad at this but the Parker
Institute the doctors there they haven't
they have their very very experienced in
finding all the injuries that torture
torture survivors have unfortunately the
vast majority of the injuries are
indicative of torture like I for
instance if I was the tide try tying a
bow tie the length of time it takes me
the muscles of my bicep tricep and along
my pectorals go into spasm and that's as
a result of muscle tears that
encouraging the torture sessions
although no direct brutality was aimed
at those the Parker Institute was able
to determine that but there are other
things that could cause that problem so
it's indicative but they have an
ultrasound scanning test of the soles of
the feet whereby they basically put a
blood pressure cuff around your calf
muscle pump it up until you've got no
blood flow into your feet it's damn
painful all right and then they slowly
release the blood flow back into your
feet while scanning your feet constantly
with ultrasound and what that does is it
highlights the fluid return into your
feet and sort of highlights the sort of
soft tissue structures in your feet as a
result and there's a peculiar pattern to
the flanger beating that the soles of
the feet that no other type of injury or
no other and no other type of normal
activity causes and with that you get
your you're proof that you can take the
court and myself Ron Jones James Carl
Alexander Mitchell James Lee James Peter
Peter Brandon myself and les Walker of
all being subjected to this test and
have all got proof positive that we were
tortured I have a second question I'm
being greedy no no no I'm here for as
long as you need me Prince Charles is I
read somewhere that he was a had a large
part in getting you guys released is a
true and what are your thoughts the
answer that is as I'm sure Prince
Charles may have been concerned because
he is he is generate humane individual
as far as I can see
but he doesn't have any real official
power import he's basically a letter
carrier when the f is on when the FCO
needs him alright and that's what he
would have been to add at a certain
cachet to the F cos efforts in reality I
think his efforts were more of a
smokescreen than they were anything else
we were released because of a hostage
exchange situation starting in October
2002 or September October 2002
negotiations were entered into involving
Saudi Arabia Britain and cap and Britain
and the United States for the release of
us in exchange for five Saudis held in
Guantanamo now that in itself is illegal
by international law it's a hostage
exchange governments are not supposed to
hold people hostage I know but that's
what they were effectively doing in this
case that deal was finalized around
about I believe February it was speeded
up and being finalized because in
February the the final sentence of my
appeal came through and it upheld that
in Saudi Arabia and it had surprise
surprise it upheld the death penalty
under which I was that I was facing once
that was over and it was agreed the five
Saudis were a writ released and released
in May then prince nani for one reason
reneged on the deal some more
arm-twisting went on and we were
released in August unfortunately in the
midst of this a rather bright spark of a
backbench MP on from various with advice
from various quarters although he claims
it came from a single mosque I'm
somewhat dubious on that conveniently at
the time just after these negotiations
took started to take place negotiations
which both the Department of Foreign
Affairs knew about and the Belgian
government knew about even though
neither government was directly involved
all of a sudden this MP he goes off gets
a letter forgiving me from and forgiving
me for killing Christopher Broadway from
the family from Justin rod way his son
and then the next thing we hear when I
come out is that this is the means that
I'm actually relieved by which I'm
released from prison in reality it was
something that irritated the hell out of
the Foreign and Commonwealth Office the
reason being is they knew about this
mechanism for years they'd used it
a couple of years previously to get a
couple of other nurses out of Saudi
Arabia who'd been sentenced to death in
Saudi Arabia for murder and they've
managed to use that they didn't want to
use it in our case because one they
actually did believe we were innocent
and therefore getting such a letter was
tacit to tacit to admitting at the state
level that we were guilty but also it
would have mean that they would have
mitad that we were guilty to this
charges of espionage that we confessed
to so in the midst of these delicate
negotiations a backbench MP goes off
gets this letter and embarrasses the
whole process I get out backbench MP now
becomes promoted to a junior minister
within the within the marking cabinet of
the Department of Foreign Affairs and
advertises on his website that basically
the only reason I'm out alive is because
of his efforts the same MP made various
promises to me when I came out of prison
about what he could do for me and
getting a public inquiry he gets his
promotion and D fate no news on that he
promised me that he would look into the
matter of the torture I had particularly
now that I had at that time I lasted a
conversation when I'll own this had
given him had shown him at that time and
then later mailed him a copy of my
report from the Parker Institute
absolutely nothing this self same MP in
July of 2004 when the hostage exchange
first broke in the news stood up and
sort of said in the media this is a very
troubling thing mr. Sampson should have
answers I'm still waiting
this MP is still getting his face all
over the papers his name is Dan McTeague
and quite frankly he's a hypocrite and
not worth voting for yep I'm here he
wants my ass in a courtroom he can have
it
I'll get up there and I will I will
state this and I have a few people I'll
subpoena to bring in to corroborate what
I'm saying any time Dan you want to sue
my ass for libel you do so that's you've
been aggressive just before we let you
come up I think that's okay tonight just
a follow-up question on something you
said you said there were five hostages
that were yeah turned over to the Saudis
what what is the fate of those people
well I saw a report
I don't honestly know what the fate of
those people is nobody really does
except I saw a report and the arab news
a few weeks back about five words about
the five saudi arabians released in 2003
having a state arranged marriage
ceremony all five at the same time being
paid for by the saudi arabian government
hey not bad you know change gears again
and you mentioned quite a while ago that
you that this your experience changed
your yourse perspective of yourself and
that you understood that that you could
survive no matter what i'm wondering if
it also brought you some new clarity in
terms of the way you perceive humanity
the answer to that question is yes what
is one of the things that helped me
survive is what i have referred to
medical rather correctly or not as our
common humanity although it's individual
to each one of it is a common it's a
common core to us and that is in my mind
the memories of those that who we have
loved in those and who have loved us in
our lives and those are memories that
can never be taken away from you they're
part of you okay Alzheimer's might do it
to you eventually but the thing is is
that in is that what the torturers do to
you cannot take that away from you and
it's into that that you retreat or at
least that that which you which I
retreated and I think it is in to that
which you need to retreat to survive
what I went through and in turn that
teacher that experiences teaching see
the value of that when my question and
now that you're not in retreat what what
do you enjoy one thing having the key to
the front door of my flat that's a great
just to be quite honestly just about
anything I can sit although I'm quite
sure there's a few crime prevention
officers out there who might be a bit
worried about this but I can sit for
hours watching kid kids play I could
never have done that before I've always
liked young kids in the rest of and
always find them amusing but I couldn't
sit there like some idiot for hours just
laughing my head off
right now I can do although in this day
and age probably some people have
worries about that but the thing is is
that just sitting and effectively doing
nothing exactly but being able to having
the freedom to be able to do that
particularly to do that with somebody
that I'm close to is probably the
greatest joint I have now is that for
you a sort of ultimate definition of
freedom to be able to do yes that is my
new definition of freedom to have the
choice to be able to enjoy that time
thank you you're not going to go back
and do your old job you have a new
career tell us about that well I was
trying when I came out of prison and I
put myself in counseling the thing there
was that I was scratching around for
something to do and I put in job
applications was getting nowhere and
didn't expect to in the short term but
put in 41 got 41 rejections the type of
work I'm liable to be useful for him the
case I'm involved in the fact that I was
deciding to sue the Saudi Arabians the
the fact that I've been out of the
workforce in a particularly unpleasant
sort of circumstances for a considerable
period of time tended to mean that I was
effectively unemployment unemployable as
a management consultant or whatever the
type of job I had done before so I
wasn't sure what I was going to do and
it was my shrink who said want to become
a lawyer now I never thought it'd become
a lawyer because I've never had much
time for lawyers in reality
I tend to view the much the same way I
did for politicians and considering that
most politicians are also lawyers you
can kind of see why voice out of
somewhat cynical attitude towards that
sort of thing and whilst I do happen to
believe that lawyers are necessary you
know a necessary function of society so
we're sewage treatment plants you still
don't have to fall in love with them I
just think I've probably completely
alienated the entire faculty of law that
I'll be studying under for that topic in
this case am I going to law school is
you can guarantee I'm not going to be
chasing after a job on Bay Street
because I'm Maya decay at the age of
fifty years old when I came out there
but the only area of law that I can work
in that somebody would employ me in is
in human rights law which is the lowest
paid end of the legal profession anyway
unfortunately we haven't talked yet
about Guantanamo Bay we've alluded to
the US but that's a that's an area that
you're particularly outraged by well we
in the West ending I include Canada as
well as the United States Britain
Western Europe spend all of our
government attempts even though they
don't enforce it attempt to sort of
stand on some moral high ground
concerning human rights abuses and then
what do we see in our press and what
what does what leaks out is that people
are being held innocent people are being
held in a facility in Guantanamo Bay and
they're being abused they're being
subjected to what is been meat has been
jokingly referred to as torture light
there is no such bloody thing as torture
light there is torture end of story
sleep deprivation which is supposed to
be torture light can result in organ
failure and permanent psychological
damage that conforms that the definition
of what is tortured by an cat the United
Nations Convention Against Torture
Americans seem to think it's justified
waterboarding can do the same thing even
though they now have legal opinions
saying
it's waterboarding they put a guy down
put towels or his face and pour water
over him to give the sensation of
drowning it can it can in certain
extreme cases induce heart attacks do
the panic and fear that it causes
particularly somebody's slightly
susceptible but it can also cause
psychological damage which can be
permanent so it again conforms to uncap
but that's now legitimized but what is
even more frightening about it than just
the fact that the Americans have for
some unknown reason decided to go ahead
and sanctify this as a means of
protecting their citizens so they can
get information on terrorism but that
our own governments Britain even Canada
even countries such as Sweden have been
involved in assisting the Americans and
rendering people not just to Guantanamo
Bay but to countries like Jordan whose
Becca Stan and Egypt where they are
further brutalized all you have to do is
take a look at the Aurora case but even
as far back as 1999 the Washington
Report Post reported that the CIA was
conducting this was doing these things
was doing these illegal renditions with
the assistance of governments such as
that such as those of Canada and the
United States how the hell can we stand
on a moral high ground and complain
about countries that are committing such
barbarity when we ourselves are
collusive in it we don't get our own
hands dirty we just shipped that we just
sort of subcontracted to some brute
somewhere you know you know go for hire
your local hit man to beat up your
neighbor because he's playing a stereo
too loud that's the mentality of that
behavior and I find it quite frankly
disgusting the worst thing about it is
the fact that there is even some people
fairies including some quite liberal
intellectuals on this I find very
surprising who have tried to legitimize
it by saying that there are times when
we have to engage in morally repugnant
acts to protect the greater good well I
would agree I personally agree with that
statement
there are certain morally repugnant
things that we do have had our history
and may have to do in the future to
protect the greater good in 1939 we went
to what we went and fought a war against
Nazi Germany war is morally repugnant
but that war was necessary it may have
been preventable but when eventually
came
we had to fight it but torture is not a
morally repugnant act that protects the
greater good it is simply a morally
repugnant act that is a political
mistake and a mistake in terms of
intelligence gathering it's a political
mistake because it builds up a well of
resentment amongst the populations from
which the victims are drawn and acts as
a recruiting drum for the very
organizations that you wish to defeat
and in terms of its potential for
gathering of accurate intelligence I
will refer to the address is made by
Condoleezza Rice and : Powell to the
Senate and to the Congress respectively
and also to and also the address of :
Powell to the United Nations justifying
the war in Iraq in which they used
evidence that Iraq was allied with
al-qaeda that had been gained from
interrogations conducted primarily in
Egypt which have since been shown to be
false confessions we now have a
justifying justification for a war in a
country such as Iraq now I'm not saying
that Saddam Hussein shouldn't be
overthrown by somebody I mean dictators
like that shouldn't have a long shelf
life but the fact was that you had bad
intelligence used for a bad purpose
because torture leads primarily to false
confessions and when you spend your time
gathering that type of information you
have your intelligence operatives
running down false leads and bad
information which leads to further human
rights abuses and it doesn't protect
your citizenry because they're not
actually doing the job that they're
being paid for which is gathering good
intelligence insurgency movements like
al-qaeda and terrorist organizations
like al-qaeda have primarily been
defeated in the past not by the use of
torture but by the use of informants and
moles in Britain in the 1970s they faced
a major problem with the IRA and that's
still an ongoing problem but the IRA was
over a period of 15 or so years as
eventually brought
the negotiating table not by the use of
internment which was arrested without
arrest and detention without trial not
only that only increased the increased
the recruitment rate both in the
Catholic and Protestant paramilitaries
it it wasn't brought to a standstill by
beating the suspect beating up the
suspects all that it was a result in a
couple of bad trials and false
conviction and false and false arrests
and false imprisonment in the UK the
Guildford four in the Birmingham sev and
the Birmingham seven who were used whose
cases were used in Isle in Northern
Ireland by the IRA to increase their
recruitment what it was broken by was by
informants and moles that were buried
deep inside the IRA and as a result
major arms caches were found their
supply of arms dwindled they're bombing
attempts although there were many that
got through the net didn't to such an
extent that they eventually were
exhausted and were brought to the
negotiating table not everything was
prevented because it not everything is
preventable but that's how it was
defeated and the same can be said about
the Algerian the insurgency in Algeria
in the 1950s against French colonial
rule every time you look at something
like that you beat insurgencies by
burrowing inside the organization and
defeating them that way by good
intelligence methods tried and tested
intelligence methods we work that have
been working for some time torture day
isn't one of them though and it doesn't
make us safer
it actually makes us less safe next
question just wondering about kind of
along the lines of what the lady asked
before about your perspective on
humanity but would you say this is a
really simple question but the world is
mostly a good place or mostly a bad
place you know is it 50/50 or what's
your perspective now that you've seen
and lived through what you have that's
my answer that is I don't think the
world is a good or a bad place I mean I
still don't I still like my the jury for
me the jury is still out on that score
what I do say is is that there are 6.5
billion people in the world
approximately less than 1 billion of
them live in countries where they are
not at risk of torture that they are not
at risk of automatic false imprisonment
we have cases
a few and few too many cases of wrongful
arrests and wrongful imprisonment in
Canada but those are usually mistakes
they're not a matter of state policy
however even so the mechanisms for
addressing those are still not
completely adequate however we do
generally in the West live in countries
that are free and open and have a decent
judiciary the majority of the planet
doesn't they are as at-risk as I was in
Saudi Arabia so that's not a good thing
about the planet on the other side of
that coin I happen to know that while I
was in prison Saudi Arabian nationals I
knew protested too long and too hard and
ended up being corrected for taking my
side in other words they were willing to
take a risk on behalf of their friends
and that side of things is what I
consider the good side of humanity most
of the people most of the people are
goods but it's most of the people are
good but it would seem the Power has
this bad habit of corrupting and that
without adequate challenges to Authority
power ultimately corrupts and it leads
to the situation's about thought I hope
you find yourself in in Saudi Arabia or
that we find in one town and when I will
great most touching things in your book
is the examples you cite of individuals
who put themselves at risk in prison to
offer you a little bit of comfort yeah
that's right I mean not all my guards
are brutes the route of let's say
one-third of them it's interesting that
if there was an experiment called the
Stanford Prison Experiment done around
about 1970 which is a mock prison
situation and what they tended to find
and that was that one third of the
people participate participating as
guards kind of got off on their
authority and were a bit brutal one
third were completely neutral and just
went by the book and one third were
quite humane and that is literally the
pattern that I found in prison in other
words without an adequate system of
control people will tend to do you tend
to find that pattern developing now it
was claimed that that was a natural
pattern that will always happen in the
Stanford Prison Experiment repeats of
though that experiment done recently
over with some profs in the UK has shown
that it's not necessarily what will
happen it's something that happens if
you don't set the guidelines in other
words you
don't create the conditions of authority
and control within the prison system and
that means that the people what that
actually means is the people who are
have ultimate responsibility the senior
civil servants the people who set policy
have to be the ones who who make sure
that those conditions don't exist to
prevent that from happening in the next
instance and it's the same with the
Milgram experiments from prior to that
that we do
yeah well the Milgram note the Milgram
ones were actually even more frightening
cuz they were done about ten years
before the Stamford ones and what they
showed is the people people are a bit or
thunk people in general most humanity
for most of his subjects were a bit
authority bound and that if you're given
an order to do something you tend to
carry it out and in this experiment that
the one group of these subjects were
actually having to give electric shocks
to another subject they didn't realize
that the subject wasn't getting
receiving electric shocks the person who
was receiving them was actually an actor
who wasn't wired up but the thing was is
that they they were the the actor was
given tasks to perform and if he failed
in those tasks he was given a shock
until he got them right with the voltage
being increased each time and sigmaz at
66% of all the subjects participating
actually increased the voltage to a
level that was marked on the monitor as
lethal and and all hundred on 100% of
the subjects ramped up the voltage
around up the voltage levels to
three-quarters of the way there
all right at the insistence of the
supervisor who was standing over the
saying this is what you have to do and
unfortunate that means we that in other
words if the conditions of authority are
put in place we'd have a habit of
behaving them
I don't think it's a sin not to stand up
to Authority and yeah but I don't I
wasn't really I wasn't really part of I
wasn't really part of the lines and they
didn't necessarily understand the issues
and I don't think it's a sin not to
stand up to Authority at all right it's
gonna be because it's extremely
difficult to stand up to Authority you
have to be a complete bloody idiot like
I am at times and to do it but and in
general most of the authority emotions
the abuses that you see of authority or
within a country such as kin are
actually quite minor so they're not
going to come up on your radar however
when you do see within your own country
at least and gross abuses of authority
you should be out there protesting if
you're not doing yourself any good by
not doing so you're not doing your
society any good a democracy is only as
good as the challenges it can withstand
all right and if the authorities the
civil servants and the politicians are
not challenged aggressively enough and
often enough they get to seem to think
that they actually own you that you work
for them and in reality the power
relationship should be the other way
around and it's only by challenging them
that one you maintain democracy until
you keep them in check and so they're
not all you don't have to sort of jump
up and down on them every day of the
week although that might not be such a
bad idea really you do have to on
certain issues particularly on issues of
civil liberties be willing to write your
MPs to protest about this sort of thing
next question there was a small clip on
him about two years ago on television on
CBC they didn't actually have his
picture but he'd been released but then
he disappeared and the emails he was
sending me he was saying that one of the
things they did to him and I'm not sure
if it was that one of those women
torturers that they had in Iraq that
tortured him but he was stripped and he
was naked and apparently in the Muslim
religion which I'm rather ignorant of
unfortunate but I gathered that that's
one of the worst things you could ever
do to a Muslim man is to strip them and
he lost his self his self-respect and he
they took away his
coma pills he didn't have his access to
he needed psychology treatments and so
on all of those things he took all his
money and they released him after a few
months but I wondered if anyone had
heard of this man because in the last
two years he's gone silent and he said
he wanted to die and he was - he was out
but he had no country he couldn't come
back to Canada because he didn't have a
passport and nor could he they took his
green card he couldn't go back to the
States
so is this man still alive or did he
commit suicide or what happened to him
does anybody know the answer that is it
it's one case that I don't know of but
unfortunately I would suspect in a case
like that it's the worst particularly if
he was abandoned and if he was dumped
out of the prison in Iraq with no means
and in need of some need of a lot of
medical attention without sufficient
contacts in Iraq he's probably fallen
off the radar he may not be he may well
have taken his own life and I'm finding
it weird because he should have gone off
hey there's me said putting a plug in
for the Department of Foreign Affairs he
should have gone to the I don't know
whether it was a console there or
whether there's a Canadian office there
in Baghdad but then it would have been
about he was released when about two
years ago and mentioned the case and it
was shortly after that that he totally
disappeared and I tried to re-enter
Assisi in Calgary in his case and they
just basically were not interested why
would why would we lose interest in this
man
and they just dropped it I can't speak
for all of the media happily but I will
tell you that the media tends to have a
short attention span and if something
drops off the radar often they'll forget
about it or they'll lose track of it I'm
glad you've raised this because you've
got my curiosity going now you and I
should talk afterwards and Farah welcome
I mean this is this is one of the things
I know as you said the media can have a
short extent attention span but it also
becomes difficult if the guy himself is
sort of dropped off the radar is a news
desk unfortunately we will come down to
money in this case he's a news desk
gonna send a reporter out to Baghdad to
go searching for a guy they might not
you know they don't really know they
don't know where he is and they don't
even know if he's in Baghdad or wherever
they wherever they dumped him and
unfortunately that means he will have
dropped off the radar but if you can
look up and look it up
are we helpful it's we've had a good
session I think unless anyone has any
final question so I have one final
question for you God and then we'll let
you go and that is we talked a bit about
getting after our local MPs but I don't
think there's anybody who has read your
book or listen to you to you who doesn't
come away with the sense that I really
want to do something as a citizen what
would you tell the people of this room
to do push your MPs to support the state
of the reform of the state immunity act
when he comes up to push your MPs to
ratify to persuade the government to
ratify the voluntary the optional
protocol of the United Nations
Convention Against Torture which is just
coming up when I've just heard about it
through Alex Nev of Amnesty
International wants me to put my name to
it which Institute which is a given the
optional protocol calls for
international effectively for an open
and international Inspectorate of
prisons much with much more wide-ranging
powers
than the current United Nations a report
or has and I again it is the sort of
thing of creating an atmosphere openness
in regimes that have prisons including
Canada having our own prisons open for
proper inspection at an international
level by an independent international
inspector II is actually a good idea
it's a very very good idea because
abuses do happen in our prisons and not
as I said as a matter of policy but
because of the circumstances and because
I will be quite frank with you now say
there's some pretty difficult people in
our prison system who quite frankly
probably deserve to be there that
doesn't mean they should be treated like
humanely it's just they deserve to be
there
and so having some form of Inspectorate
level at an international level to which
we can be held accountable isn't a bad
thing for the Canadian prison system
we're not perfect but it's also
something that should be pushed in all
other countries Canada maybe we should
take a lead in this be an example and on
that score again ask your MPs what are
they what their position is on signing
up to the optional protocol of the
United Nations Convention Against
Torture those are two very practical
things you can press your MPs on alright
one more question Thank You mr. Sampson
have you within confessions of an
innocent man reference to the Canadian
MP that you've mentioned in relations no
I was writing a lot of this stuff up I
was writing a lot of this stuff up at
the time that I ended up going into
hospital have my gallbladder removed and
everything kind of went slightly
pear-shaped at that moment for the sort
of finish of the book and I had to add
some things had to be edited out at that
time the book is complete in itself but
as I said certain of the politics of it
that I have was unable to complete in
time would you please gather Teague MC
te a gue Liberal MP for a Jack Pickering
family name once again MC te a gu e
victory of Pickering Ajax Pickering
thanks revenge
he's also the Jew he's also the
parliamentary secretary to to Pierre
Pettigrew of Minister of Foreign Affairs
which means he's a junior minister is
easy to find well on that note I want to
thank you for coming to Calgary to tell
your story
oh one more question the MP was making a
push for the legal means for redress
referring to the block no no I'm
wondering about that one who you
referred to me referred as pushing
forward a bill okay got the wrong ones
okay we just talked to cross purposes my
fault I forget the other guy
it's Francine lalande Lal oh and de
Francine Francine yep but I'm along for
that okay thank you
okay good did I ever get that one wrong
it's been a long day folks well again we
thank you for coming to Calgary to tell
your story you're a man of incredible
courage I think it takes a lot of
courage to put into a book the
experiences that you live through and
our hope is that it will change the
attitudes of the Canadian government
that it will have an impact with
Canadian citizens but again thanks for
coming out tonight